so
this guy and I remember this guy because
we we meant we covered some of his stuff
not this but when we were covering the
trucker Convoy we are not knowing who he
was we found this verified guy this
these Blundell guy Dean Blundell guy he
was the guy that was snitching on and
doxing the people that were at the
trucker rally oh so God's work to their
job yeah God's work and then somebody I
think it was what's the name of that
[ __ ] band five times August or
something some band I don't know they
are but they're not but they're actually
whatever pretty base because they've
always been anti-lockdown and they were
he was talking to him and he reminded
Dean Blundell of this tweet looks like
we got a couple of Jesus slash covet
slash Q Anon related deaths slash
homecomings to celebrate kids
so basically this is when you know
people were dying and he was uh why
why are they like this man I never
wished anything on even like the the
profaxers the pro like yeah there is
probably at least I don't know a hundred
people I feel should go to prison and
never will
but like everyday retards like 90 of
them fouchy
uh but like you know the the retards
have fell for it I I have a little bit
of empathy I have a shred of empathy
reserved still for but I I was never
like oh I hope this vax kills people I
hope that I hope now you're I hope
you're wrong and you [ __ ] die like
that's when it got weird for me I'm like
whoa why are you wishing death on people
I I have not done that to you sir or
ma'am or both uh Dean Blundell uh snitch
blogger the doc says gifts and go donors
or previously reprimanded for making
sexual comments about children now I'm
going I'm going to be fair I'm gonna be
fair I have to be fair
I read into it and it was 2009 edgy boy
jokes Royce can I ask yes was yeah
shock Chuck well this is what I was
shocked to find out no pun intended when
I mentioned this guy both Frozen and
pessy were like
he was like the big at one point the
biggest shock shock in Canada which I
don't know if that means much but he was
but it's something then he got fired and
he got moved around and it was your
typical shock jock humor that everybody
was [ __ ] doing uh now he does an
exclusive just a podcast
um that's that's basically that's
basically a big show that's basically
all is let me see something because I
gotta see something oh okay this is uh
yeah so I figured uh no it's it's it's
pretty big
um this this one here this is when he
streamed a day ago has 853 views that's
some solid biggest shock jock but here's
the problem
buddy
maybe you shouldn't have gone you
shouldn't have waited before going live
what do you think huh because he's live
right now so I figure what if we pop in
and listen to the shock chalk that wants
you dead people around you and start
doing it again
so yeah go ahead first real quick
all right here's what I'm gonna do
because I you know you don't have it
because we weren't expecting to do this
I'm going to go ahead and send you the
link okay thank you all right I sent him
through the YouTube chat oh no it's
going to be hard to find I'll send it
through the rumble chat that's going to
be difficult to find you know what's a
smaller chat the locals chat there you
go all right I didn't need it um oh guys
do me a favor disregard that thank you
ignore that that link was just for me
yes please ignore it thank you and I I
don't think I'm wrong here oh 98. you
went from 68 to 98. what's up shock Jack
bro doubling down saying that they hope
that they died now while we wait for the
for for people to find his show he
blocked me I went to his merch store you
ready this is his merch store this is
the Dean Blundell merch store okay the
guy who wants you dead laughs about it
I swear to drunk I'm not God because
when you're drunk you become dyslexic I
never got that joke I never I never got
that joke I I oh I'm not officer drunk
you're not like you don't mix I've never
in my life become dyslexic from booze I
I've gotten slurry yeah
oh here's another one maybe it's the
beer talking but I really like beer
buddy that's a thing about it merge
that's you like beer what's better than
a shirt you buy at a Myrtle Beach
[ __ ] gift shop
Dean Blundell coven refugee I was about
to make the same joke but for Virginia
Beach but by the way and I could have
made that joke about [ __ ] Dania Beach
I could have made the joke about Key
West every Beach town has these places I
survived the Rapture oh by the way
he's also [ __ ] edgelord Evangelical
atheist he also has this shirt
uh
uh which is if your goals set you
whatever so it's it's this Jamie sale
this is a basically one of the Convoy
people she blocked him and he was so
proud of it he made her shirt but here's
the thing Dean why'd you block me
because I'm about to make an ROTC shirt
and it's going to sell better than your
shitty shirt you piece of [ __ ]
um so as you can see now let me show you
my favorite shirt
the edgiest boys of all edgy boys what
do you think of this one
what do you think of that one huh
he's edgy bro
what's happening oh 177 how many times
he might be excited about all the new
listeners yeah he probably is we should
check in what's going on why is your
stream dying
and has yeah but I I've stepped up
because I would rather deal with that
negative that sort of that energy that I
get and that Rush of adrenaline I'd
rather deal with that than the regret of
not saying something come on tell them
to die they're in the chat now Dean
and and again that's me that's what I'm
going oh God the chat room we aren't
dead yet hamwork order I've been I've
been Nick ricada got his channel back
God damn it who said that one that's my
favorite
that was a good one okay let me let me
I'm gonna type it I'm gonna type one say
this Virgie is men really try to examine
oh other people are typing virgius but
nice
in this case
somebody just notices dead teeth he has
dead teeth
in the last couple of years and it was
you wanted us dead right
having some lunch where are you now and
it's kind of funny that you changed the
videos focused as a guest that's talking
today you know you could panic in the
chat room oh that's right is that what's
happening this isn't the guy this is the
guest Danny's saying Dean fears Royce
Lopez of day Wave radio uh-oh are you
guys donating
come on
Frazier is British
what are you guys doing guys do not
start writing Niles in there please
merch and I have done radio long enough
to know what's happening here somebody
has to do something and the other guy's
covering and taking over like this come
on Dean
and Dean has been a big help as he tries
to be funny about this stuff but Dean is
well has he ever succeeded
and being funny with me with where I'm
at with this [ __ ]
well and hold it but but the thing about
it is and I don't think people
understand it when they when they have
conversations about things change the
camera Dean you forgot that you forgot
you're in stream yard just hit the
switch in the camera Dean you have to
switch the camera Dean yeah not the one
that shows your Facebook comments yeah
Dean the other one Dean
let's go Dean
it's totally different
it's back there he is
yeah
what's going on guys what happened are
you losing control what's going on it
kind of man you know what if we all
would have died because we didn't get
the vaccine this wouldn't have happened
huh yeah I know but we're all alive
right this is fun we're talking about
are we having fun now we're talking
about
guys you know what I'm here you know
what I'm here for us
amnesty Ambassador we're covet amnesty
ambassadors that's where you lose me
right so now when I look at whoever said
is this an lgbtq plus friendly Channel
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you're
awesome
bother me one bit my friend Niles hasn't
been vaccinated what do somebody just
donated that
have a decent conversation and you know
hope people are dying because I'm a
shark
Clyde Hey Dean new fan here my mom died
of cancer not as funny as covet I know
but I hope you still get a giggle from
it holy [ __ ] [ __ ] quiet
God damn that was a [ __ ] kill shot oh
literal
better or worse for them here's the
thing I gotta do I don't give a [ __ ]
because I can't control any of it and if
and if I the only thing I know the dude
on the bottom right is laughing at some
of it too he keeps losing it and
giggling yeah
I have the ability sometimes to go [ __ ]
I'm going to hit these people back twice
as hard like a dump truck come on come
on bring the dump truck homeboy let's go
you don't even have guns anymore what
are you gonna do hey I want to be clear
and I know those Canadian listeners I'm
sorry Jim Edward but you understand you
only exist because we allow you to right
like it's super important that Canadians
remember that okay you are only allowed
to do your little [ __ ] of social
experiment and have your your gay black
face prime minister because we have guns
and we let you okay
all right I think I got muted oh they're
meeting a lot of people these people
there's a reason why we get spam I
wanted to ask most of our unvaxed
audience is still alive your show oh I
never give them what they want and you
know what I take from them they're
[ __ ] brains and I live for it because
that's what they're trying to do to us
and so it's so easy because they're so
stupid hey stop talking out of the side
of your mouth like a [ __ ] idiot
because you think it makes you look cool
hey hey by the way you could do cope you
could do cope Fest 2022 if you want you
could do oh by look he's triggering
Christians buddy you think I give a [ __ ]
about you making fun of Christians I
don't I don't but so it's not gonna work
either you get that
you get it you [ __ ] Leaf piece of
[ __ ] day of the rake [ __ ]
but
but it's just again explain to the folks
at home what vaccination is
just what is by the way guys I I know
this is really mean but the woman on the
bottom left is still a Canadian seven
are them ignore me ignore me it's
ridiculous you guys are doing a good job
at ignoring oh hey by the way they're
doing great hey by the way guys if they
do not read your super chats you request
a refund okay
please hear me out if they do not read
your super chats you request a refund
for every single one of them until they
take away their monetization for too
many refunds okay so make sure you read
them we need no satisfaction well and
and so for you what do you mean your
audience of nobody you [ __ ] nobody
listen when Elon took over Esther when
Elon took over Twitter I was like
because Here Comes deaner it's like he's
coming in hot because like listen I'm
sorry this is a shock joke
you know how to insult without defaming
I'm getting my comments you know how to
insult without defaming do you know
what's in it for me watching them lose
their [ __ ] watching them like dedicate
these are human beings that are like I'm
gonna go into a chat room and act like a
tool I'm gonna spend the entire day
doing these hey guys let's watch them
okay I'm gonna sit back right now and
watch him not care because I just hate
this guy that I've never met but he
tweets these things that make me crazy
that's why I do it like
yeah in the chat right now like holy
crap what is I
yeah the world ended when Elon yeah
these are just crazy people that don't
and you know here's the other great part
of it we're just watching them cope
these receipts in almost every single
one of those YouTube accounts will be
taken out by the time I get off this
thing because
I get what I want yeah but in the end by
the way by the way hey first day on
YouTube bro do you think
by the way as as somebody
as a show who has received a lot of
[ __ ] spam chats they don't care bud
they don't care and what I'm doing right
now is transformative and I don't think
I've broken it broken any Torres do you
it's not for me
um it's not for her it's not for her
it's not for her listen you're getting
the reaction you want you're right you
are but here's the thing
I mean your [ __ ] head now and that's
the issue you can't do a show anymore
because the problem is unlike the
[ __ ] like merch and I who are used
to doing the show with a [ __ ] crazy
chat room you don't know how to do it
you rely on it because you have nothing
else you're a hack your entire life is a
[ __ ] it's led up to you being on a
being a 65 year old man doing a podcast
for 60 people does that feel good does
that feel good oh and by the way elon's
gonna take away your little check mark
and then you're gonna be down in the
slums with us you piece of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] nobody selling your [ __ ] Key
West beach shirts like you [ __ ]
matter you don't you you sped on the
wrong horse you should have hoped we
were dead huh you should have [ __ ]
hoped we were dead but we didn't we
survived and yes it goes through uh I'm
writing our unjabbed audience is a
hundred times the size of yours did your
audience die
that is brilliant person schedules
oh which was that a night wave no it's
going to come from we're not sorry got
it
hey guys
don't forget if you're not if you don't
like what he's saying to make sure you
let him know by by let you could you
know they can't see it but if he's
coming after you YouTube does let you
let him know you should always downvoted
if you don't like it I'm not telling you
to do that I'm saying don't forget that
option is still there
we do to I think everything that's gone
down I've definitely I by the way um I
want to thank I want to thank uh Dean
Blundell that is just spamming we're
dogsing you right now on Twitter
it's so stupid
it's so stupid photos YouTube channels
are gonna be gone it's a good thing I'm
out of here in December buddy and
honestly we could go sooner you want us
to go tomorrow we know parachutes are
already on our backs our golden
parachutes are ready to go [ __ ]
so uh this doesn't end
this doesn't end now by the way you're
welcome I just made you more money today
than you've made in the past life so
good luck guy by the way bro [ __ ] if
you're a real man you'll read your super
chats
by the way if they don't read them you
can ask for a refund it's super
important you know that
oh look he got us he just opened the
chat Jesus isn't real hey
okay
all right
Jesus hey guys Jesus isn't real
here's the thing about Jesus not being
real it's the same thing as risking your
uh your entire life by taking an
experimental medical treatment let's say
I'm wrong
it doesn't affect me in any way but in
both of your positions in life if you're
wrong it's real bad for you if I'm wrong
I'm just wrong very good point if Jesus
isn't real then I'm just gonna die and
go away and finally get some goddamn
rest so that's fine if I if I'm wrong
about the facts I could always get it
later
now I'm typing something out here I'll
turn it up so we can see them cope so
when I heard about Esther's story and
this is why you came on the show I think
is I couldn't retweet her story enough
and her GoFundMe which by the way is in
the description here at deanblundell.com
of the entire podcast go to YouTube Dean
Blundell show on YouTube twitch Dean
Blondell TV on Twitch you can see it and
you can donate to Esther because she has
almost lost her home uh her she's got
two beautiful kids two beautiful
children if I'm not mistaken
um her and her husband work very hard
they're incredible citizens and they
were they were almost not only bullied
out of their lives weren't you like a
shock chat guy though yeah he's funny
jokes about [ __ ] kids
so like yeah we're not we're not not
having a conversation about oh you know
just block I mean you can't block it
when it comes to your doorstep and you
get looking over your shoulder and you
you know you've got people he's what
he's talking about is more censorship he
wants crazies he wants more censorship
see he wants he wants more censorship uh
they're calling him now in the chat
Great Value Keith over a minute no
revenge and assists Jesus may not be
real but we are there's a storm coming
Dean and it's unvaxed disaster couldn't
afford she didn't have that opportunity
this is what we do for living she's a
[ __ ] English Professor Carlton oh
he's always angry why are you so mad
aren't you supposed to be jovial you
little shock Chuck what's going on big
guy
all right I'll tell you what today's fun
I like today today is super fun but [ __ ]
this guy
um wow you the most money you're ever
gonna make huh you're welcome big box
big buckaroons big dollars you know what
that you know what that is for us
a Tuesday
maybe Dean's like ricada he doesn't read
anything under 20 bucks oh that's fair
that's fair no big shot the Revenge of
the cyst died of covet somebody said
oh [ __ ] all right anyway
I think we're good for now though huh
should we leave him alone we have other
stuff
everyone go out now everyone leave
everyone at the same time
now now now go go go go go go go and by
the way if he didn't read it
you make sure you're refunded okay
can you not see his numbers of how many
people are watching live is uh 165. oh
okay they changed oh you wonder what he
started with because I looked before 30
something it was 61.61 yeah shock jock
biggest shock Chuck by the way guess
what you don't exist anymore so anyway
let's move on what do you say yeah
everyone boom now everyone just [ __ ]
bail right now empty it
just the numbers go away
by the way we never got to him
I mean oh God look at the numbers the
numbers really are just disappearing by
the way 118. we never got to him
so Dean Jesus isn't real guys
why'd you block me Dean If you like this
so much why'd you block me
Dean
you know what Marsh you know what we
should do she's a maritimes for
rhinestone hangman page said she's a
maritimes for oh you guys are brutal I
just subscribed because we should
probably keep a look after all yeah I
want to make sure that it seems like a
good show it does okay so
um man we haven't done that in a while
and that felt really nice it's been a
bit it's been a bit right it feels
and that guy I feel no shame about he's
a piece of [ __ ]
um